what exactly does your robot do so the
night scope autonomous data machine we
call it the k5 roams around on its own
autonomously meaning not remote control
and it can see feel hear and smell and
think of it as smart eyes and ears for a
private security guard or police officer
do their jobs that much more effectively
what William is this deployed anywhere
where people can actually see how it
works
we're in beta testing right now and
obviously the media is taking a great
level of attention to what we're doing
so we're in testing now and we're gonna
do some larger deployments next year
here in Silicon Valley Stacy Stephens
you have a background in law enforcement
I want you to view can to describe if
this was operational if the k5 robot was
operational and had been deployed
previously let's say in a place like
Ferguson Missouri what kinds of
information would we have access to well
first and foremost but you need to
understand from a law enforcement
perspective is the robot actually is a
commanding presence so if you for
example put a police car on the side of
the road or in front of the building it
immediately changes criminal behavior so
that's where it's going to have the
first effect secondly it's looking for
those anomalies it's looking for
anything that's out of place or
nefarious is taking place and it's going
to send an alert back to a Security
Operations Center so that if human can
actually look at that and make a
determination as to whether or not
somebody needs to be there William the
technology that goes into this
particular robot describe all the
details if you can what kind of info
would we get temperature motion
detection so it's a great mashup of
technology of all the greatest things
are going on in Silicon Valley it's
robotics its sensors autonomous
technology big data predictive analytics
so it's combination of looking at
360-degree daytime nighttime video
thermal imaging we can run 300 license
plates a minute and run it against the
national database so let's say there's a
fellow in tag to a particular plate
hyperlocal weather almost any sensor
payload on there that when and again
enable the machine to provide a
intelligence for our first responders to
do their jobs that much better how much
would something like this cost William
we offer this in a machine as a service
business model so it's six dollars and
25 cents per hour as opposed to security
guards usually 25 or 35 dollars an hour
but it's not for a one-for-one human
machine replacement so one would have
probably let's say 7 machines and 3
highly trained guards to be able to
secure a let's say a high value target
much more effectively and the last point
to you Stacy Stevens
what kind of reaction have you gotten
from law enforcement officials to
introduce this you know we've had a
tremendous amount of support we have
numerous police agencies who have asked
us if they could help